TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Google Developers
Launchpad Studio
provides tailored technical
and product support
to artificial intelligence
and machine learning startups,
all in one place.
For more on the services
provided and a link to apply,
head on over to the post linked
in the description below.
The annual meeting
of the Association
for Computational
Linguistics or ACL
happened this week in Vancouver.
It's the premier conference in
the field of natural language
understanding.
To learn more about
the papers, workshops,
and tutorials that Googlers
contributed this year,
check out the post.
The latest Playbook app
is now available to help
you learn about features,
best practices, and strategies
to succeed on Google Play.
With it, you can discover
insights from Google
to help you develop
and launch your app,
engage and grow your audience,
and earn more revenue.
Version 1.0 of the Android
testing support library
is now available.
It's a major update to
our existing testing APIs
and comes with lots of new
features, improved performance,
stability, and bug fixes.
Details, diagrams, and
code are on the post.
Developer Preview 4 of
the Android O platform
is now available.
It's a good time to
wrap up your testing
and publish your updates to give
your users a smooth transition
to Android O.
The official Dart
Conference this year
will be on January 23rd
and 24th in Los Angeles.
It will be even
bigger and better
than last year with talks on
Dart 2.0, Flutter, Dart Dev
Compiler, AngularDart,
and much more.
For pre-registration,
head on over to the post.
Adobe recently announced their
plans to end support for Flash
in late 2020.
For Flash developers, this will
mean transitioning to HTML,
as Chrome will increasingly
require explicit permission
from users to run Flash content
until support is removed
completely at the end of 2020.
For some links to help
make the transition,
take a look at the post.
The web-based Code
Editor in Cloud Shell
makes it easier to edit source
code within the browser.
And it's now in beta.
To see some screenshots
and learn about the latest
improvements, check out the
post linked in the description
below.
Please remember to Like,
Subscribe, and Share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
Thanks for tuning into this
week's episode of The Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of the prior episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]